the medium not state muzzled their state
produced so the state doesn't even need
to muzzle them in China the government
is muzzling the media in Russia it
simply owns most of the media and simply
produces the news at wants and doesn't
pay attention to the other news so
there's there's a big distinction there
it's it's interesting how different
those two countries are Russia does not
employ a whole lot of sensors the way
the Chinese government does so you can
you can sort of say what you like online
in Russia but if if I happen to say
something mean about the head of police
in my village I wouldn't be worried
about a sensor I'd be worried about the
police because they're not going to
censor me they're just going to come and
beat me up which is different though the
it's it's a different way of abusing
power
okay first I got to disclose something
here I'm on the board of advisors to
live journal which is live journal was
not just sold in fact well more
complicated there's a Russian company
called soup which ran livejournal and
runs livejournal within Russia they
owned that property / that community
which is a user community and this is
one of the interesting things about the
internet does owning quote the property
mean you really own the community you
may own the commercial thing but if your
user all leave you can't prevent them
from doing that so that Russian company
soup which is run by an American but
primarily owned by a russian called
Alexander moment then acquired the US
company livejournal which is a
technology company that creates the
technology platform on which livejournal
runs both in Russia and outside Russia
so there their interest is not in
squelching the voices of these users
it's pretty much to the contrary it's
their interest is in this being a lively
vibrant place that's trusted and where
people feel free to comment they they're
interested in making money so there with
some protest from some of the advisory
board members including me they're
changing the business model slightly but
they're not censoring the content now
the I've talked to them about this and
you know I said so can people say what
they like and the answer is basically
yes they can say what they like if you
criticize Putin usually someone else
will jump all over you and say how great
he is and so the authorities aren't that
worried about livejournal it's again
it's very different from in China the
authorities again they own most of the
mass media or they control them
indirectly so it's it's a different it's
a difference
now if livejournal became most people's
major source of news then livejournal
would probably face censorship by the
state but it would not impose it itself
I mean that everything changes over time
but that's sort of the situation right
now
you